Hello and welcome everyone. It's ActInf
Lab livestream number 38.0,
February 10, 2022.
We're going to be discussing the paper.
"The evolution of brain architectures for
prediction, active coding and active
inference." Welcome to the Active
Inference Lab. We are a participatory
online lab that is communicating,
learning and practicing applied active
inference. You can find us at some of
the links here on the slide. This is a
recorded and archived livestream, so
please provide us with feedback so we
can improve on our work. All backgrounds
and perspectives are welcome here and
we'll be following good video etiquette
for live streams. It's going to be a
solo stream though. Go
ActiveInference.org if you want to learn more
about how to participate or contribute
or get involved with any active project
and check out this code, a link to see
past and encoding live streams. The page
looks like this so you can see events
that haven't happened yet, like 39,
40. And then also you can look back and
you can see who is participating and
read the papers and all of that. So
check it out today in active stream
number 38. The goal is to learn and
discuss this cool paper, the Evolution
of Brain Architectures for Predictive
Coding and Active Inference. The papers
by Giovanni Pezzulo, Thomas Parr and
Karl Friston from December 21. And just
like all videos, it's just an
introduction to some of the ideas. It's
not a review or a final word. So go
check out the paper to learn more. And
there's going to be an overview with
first names and claims, abstract and
roadmap. Alright? I'm Daniel, I'm a
researcher in California. The big
question that this paper is getting at
is what is the evolutionary
neurophysiological basis of cognition
and how do complex cognitive phenotypes
arise? So how do things develop
and evolve, how they think and how does
that change over evolutionary time? And
shown here are three images representing
three scales of analysis of looking at
ant cognition. So on the left is a
representation of the synapse with the
glia wrapped around it and the molecules
and some of the mechanisms, because
changes in those mechanisms can
influence cognition. Then in the middle
is a 3D representation of an ant brain
with the different brain regions like
the central complex and the optic
and the olfactory lobes. And this
represents the level of regional or
micro or meso anatomical variation.
And that definitely changes over
evolutionary time, just like the
synaptic level. And then there's this
behavior ecological level and that's
where the ants are engaging in
collective behavior and stigma g. And so
how does this all work? How does this
all work in today's ants and how has it
evolved and then expand that to other
species and other questions?
The paper was published right at the end
of 2021 in December in
the Royal Society of Publishing.
And just to go over the aims and claims
of the paper, this is in the authors
words, there's growing consensus that
the brains of humans in other
phylogenetically derived or advanced
organisms operate in a predictive manner
across action prediction coding and
action control active inference. Yet the
ways in which our advanced predictive
abilities may have arisen during
evolution domain unclear. The goal of
this article is to sketch an
evolutionary history of brain
architecture's for predictive
processing. A central tenet of
our proposal is that although prediction
is often characterized as a complex
cognitive function, it is not a late
evolution addition of advanced animals
like us. Rather, in distinctions to a
late stage cognitive argument like
saying language is what makes us an
advanced cognizer or semantic language
with certain types of syntax.
Rather, our complex predictive
abilities, eg. Learning and imagination
emerged gradually e. G via phyletic
gradualism smooth changes to evolution
time or punctuated equilibrium sharp
changes through evolution time. But
punctuated at one scale is smooth at
another from simpler predictive and
errors correction loops e. G, motor and
autonomic reflexes that were already
part of the brains of our earlier
evolutionary ancestors and were key to
solving adaptive regulation problems.
So, just like Mike Levin's
paper was addressing the question of
basal cognition from the bioelectric
perspective, here is going to be more of
a predictive processing and action
inference perspective on the functional
aspects, not on the mechanistic. So the
bioelectric was down here at the level
of cells. This is going to be
approaching it from a little bit of a
different perspective, but we'll find
out here's the Abstract this
article considers the evolution of brain
architectures for predictive processing.
We argue that brain mechanisms for
predictive exteroception and action are
not Laje evolutionary additions of
advanced creatures like us. Rather,
they emerge gradually from simpler
predictive loops for example, autonomic
and motor reflexes that were a legacy
from our earlier evolutionary ancestors
and were key to solving their
fundamental problems of adaptive
regulation. We characterize simpler
to more complex brains formerly in terms
of generative models that include
predictive loops of increasing
hierarchical breadth and depth. These
may start from a simple homeostatic
motif and be elaborated during evolution
in four main ways. These include the
multimodal expansion of predictive
control into an allostatic loop, its
duplication to form multiple sensory
motor loops that expand an animal's
behavior repertoire and the gradual
endowment of general, generative model
models with hierarchical depth to deal.
With aspects of the world to unfold at
different spatial scales and temporal
depth, to select which plans select
plans in a future oriented manner.
In turn, these elaborations underwrite
the solution to biological regulation
problems faced by increasingly
sophisticated animals. Our proposal
aligns neuroscientific theorizing about
predictive processing with evolutionary
and comparative data on brain
architecture's in different animal
species. And just looking ahead, here's
a figure that we're going to get to
here's. The interface states it has this
structure to model and then it's going
to undergo a set of different types of
discrete operations that change it
structurally and that's structured
learning. And it's going to happen over
evolution time scale and it's going to
be tied to functional architectures for
predictive processing. Okay, how do they
go from here to there? This is the
roadmap after the interoception. They
introduce predictive regulation and
control perception, cognition and
control action as basic design
principles of the brain. So kind of
taking that embodied approach but making
it very operational and functional so
that it can be studied from brain
evolution function perspective.
Introducing the brain as doing structure
learning in generative model models over
evolutionary and also other active
states. They then give three examples
of simple predictive motifs in ancestral
brains which is the homeostatic control,
the allostasis control and the simple
behavior learning. Then they introduce
that figure that we just looked at and
that's the evolutionary algebra of
structured learning. Just like you can
multiply and add these are kind of like
operations on evolutionary spaces. They
then discuss a few finer points related
to behavior switching, temporal depth,
hierarchical depth and then take a
phylogenetic perspective at the end
given an example and there's a
discussion. Okay,
so to go into section two and just sort
of deal with the keywords and themes as
they are needed,
here's figure one. In.
Figure one. The reason why we can even
jump in here without going to any
keywords is it's biology we're
talking about? And we can jump in. Why
not as good of a place as any to go in
at the action perception loop and then
connect it to some of the analytical or
mathematical formalisms of active
inference and the free energy principle.
So this is figure one in the paper in
section two, the Action exteroception
cycle and Predictive regulation. So
here's our entity, our agent on the left
and here is our world state on the
right. The entity is engaged
in prediction while they're making
observations that are being emitted from
the world that's resulting in some
discrepancy. Either things are exactly
as expected or not. So an example would
be in the visual field. The brain is
generating a prediction of what is in
the blind spot of the retina. And then
if the eyes were to move there, to use
action changing the world in terms of
the stimuli coming in through ocular
motor action that would result in a
exafferent perception that could either
confirm or deny. Confirm with a low
discrepancy or be very surprising with a
high discrepancy. What was expected
about what was in the blind spot which
would confirm accuracy in a visual
model. And so in this partitioning of
action and perception, which is just
very descriptive, it's not quite the
Bayesian graph that we're going to get
to later. It's kind of like a flow model
and there's probably other flow models
that could be used as well. But it turns
out that this partitioning, or this way
of thinking about flow, at least
conceptually, leads to in the active
inference proposal, this idea
of using a free energy minimizing
function over some math that we'll get
to a little bit more formally in the
next figure and using a kind of combined
metric that has two parts, the red and
the Bleu, to make decisions about
perception as well as action. Because it
turns out that perception and action and
cognition and metacognition are all part
of the entity's model that it's doing
inference on in certain cases. So just
to kind of throw back to not so long
ago, here we have the F of
Q, that's the distribution that's under
the entity's control and Y. And so as a
function of beliefs and data, there's
going to be some term. And so just
looking back to 37, we looked at the
variational free energy and how that
relates to perceptual inference where
there's a penalty for overfitting as
well as a penalty for failing to explain
the data. So it's kind of making a
visual model or a perceptual model that
in that snapshot given the priors and
precision and all of that is not
overfitting, but it is fitting the data
and it's kind of existing on that
frontier and then it's using variational
inference to solve that in a really
tractable way. And then when action
comes Hinton play, a few things happen.
First the agent has to incorporate their
own preferences because why care about
action if you don't even care why it's
going to happen? So they have to
incorporate their preferences, which is
a non arbitrary in a sense for action
selection, but it's arbitrary in a
higher level as well as incorporating
the fact that there's uncertainty over
the consequences of action or just
future states of the world, not just
like sensor measurement as in other
cases. So we have to take this
variational free energy calculation that
was just like snapshot perception and
expand it a little bit to the expected
free energy. So here's F in the
background and now there's this expected
free energy term G, which is over also
an action selection policy z. And now
there's kind of similar like resonating
or Rhyming terms. But rather than
overfitting, the imperative on the left
side is to satisfy preferences on
the right side. The penalty for failing
to explain the data is kind of
transposed into this failing to minimize
expected surprise of future data. So
this is like fitting the expectations
well on the right side in Bleu and then
living up to your preferences and
expectations in an optimistic way on the
left. So it's kind of like realism on
the right and optimism on the left. And
that is what we talked about in 37 and
that's the partitioning that's being
done basically here. The authors are
setting that up as the action perception
cycle and predictive regulation. Just
wanted to kind of view 37 really quick
because it was a fun discussion that we
had. It also really sets the stage for?
How is that similar or different than
other action perception partitionings or
models? Does evolutionary psychology or
evolutionary cognition studies, do they
have a fundamental action perception
model at the root? Is that a good thing?
Is it a bad thing?
Section three goes into section two.
Gain was just about how this single
slide and represented in figure one
about this predictive. So anticipatory
but also embedded etc. Infinity loop
cycle is the basic principle of the
brain. We can't take the basic principle
of the brain to be some lower level like
just information transmission among
cells. Nor do the authors jump in at a
higher level like the fundamental unit
of cognition is linguistic tokens that
are being modified, not discrepancies
with multiple different kinds
of things that are being predicted from
this functional description of
cognition. They move to section three
formalizing brain design as structure
learning in generative models. So what
is the structure of this model and then
what does it look like to do structure
learning in that model and why is
it generative and then how is that
formalized?
So here's figure two, the generative
models and the generative process. So
the first words, the same second word is
different. So the different words and
the figure on the left side has the
entity. The figure on the right side has
the world state. So it's the same action
perception loop we saw in figure one.
And now this sort of conceptual flow
single edge model like just only one
arrow here, no extra anything, just sort
of first pass. It's compatible with
this which is actually a Bayesian graph.
But how do they describe it and what are
all the variables? We still have the
same things happening. We have the
observations coming in to the cognition
entity that's the observations coming
in. The entity
is going to infer some action policy
based upon the observations coming in
which is going to result in some change
to the actual underlying system, which
is the generative process. So that's
like the actual birds and the bees and
the sun and stuff. Allegedly it
does get into a little bit of a gray
area with the realism instrumentalism
and the structural realism. But we're
not even going to go there in this
discussion right now. The generative
process is the one that's handing out
the observations as modeled. The
generative model to close the loop is
the entity's inference. And so here is
X, the entity's prediction on hidden
state. And then here is X star which is
like the actual hidden state that is
being alleged in the world. And we've
had some other discussions about how
that's the sigma function. That's like
mapping between the two X's. That's
what's being minimized. If the
discrepancy is low, there's other
notation. How do the authors describe
it? The difference between the
generative models and the generative
process nodes
correspond to probability distributions
and edges to their statistical
dependencies. So this is like a Bayes
graph. Mathematically a generative
models may be formulated as the joint
probability density p of y
and x of observations y and hidden
states x of the world to generate those
observations. I think it was just a copy
errors. The latter are referred to as
hidden or latent states as they cannot
be observed directly. The joint
probability distribution can be
decomposed in two parts. The first is a
prior p of x, which denotes the
organism's knowledge about hidden states
of the world prior to seeing sensory
data. The second is the likelihood p
of y given x, which denotes the
organism's knowledge of how observations
are generated from states. So that's the
perceptual model. And then they go on to
describe how there's a difference
between the entity's inference on hidden
state and the actual hidden state,
which is the generative process versus
the generative model distinction. And
then they introduce Action and say
action you that's this node that
influences the hidden state, even if
zero effect is generated based upon the
inferences made under a generative
model. Action is shown here as part of
the generative model. Sorry, action is
shown here as part of the generative
process making changes to the world
despite being selected from the
inference drawn under the model. So
action is actually making influence gain
the edge could be zero in some respect,
but it's making active inference in the
world. It's like the active states
interpreted in a statistical way.
So what does that have to do with
structured learning? So the entity is
going to either whether you're a realist
and saying the entity is doing
structured learning or you're
instrumentalist, it is possible for us
as researchers today to model that
entity as doing structured learning
because it's computational efficient or
elucidative or you go full utilitarian,
you just say disregard that whole
realism instrumentalism. It's a useful
approach and I'll follow utility
wherever it goes for any number of those
reasons. You might want to model the
cognition of different entities without
going into just the philosophy of what
its cognitive process actually is. And
so one approach that's going to get
taken is using inference either
from the outside describing
instrumentally or realism as if it were
happening maybe with anatomical
evidence, as if the hidden state could
include not just parameters that were
continuous about the world, but also
structures of models.
However, it's difficult to imagine that
that type of cognitive or even extremely
metacognitive thought or action
selection could happen, for example, in
some early proto cell, however simple
it may have been. And so how do we get
from that flagella changing bacterium to
all the other kinds of cognition that we
see today, or should I say bacterium
like entity, relative or ancestor of
today's bacterium?
So how can we think about this model,
which is often described in the context
of parameter learning, and then approach
this as if it were maybe about parameter
learning sometimes. But also it could be
about structure in terms of the good
regulator and the requisite diversity,
that kind of requisite variety, those
kinds of models. Okay, the next several
sections are where they get to the
specifics and some of the contributions
of the paper that I think will be really
cool to continue the discussion on
section four is just short and it's
saying we're about to go into three
examples of simple predictive motifs and
ancestral brains. Because one of the
main claims of the paper is that these
motifs are very ancestral.
They're old motifs, they're not Johnny
come lately to the cognitive scene.
These are features that one can think of
as who knows how far back or
how simple these cognitive mechanisms
have existed, but we'll evaluate that
maybe when we get to talk together. But
first we'll just kind of go through how
they define them and use them. The three
predictive motifs are homeostasis
allostasis and simple behavioral
control. So first, five generative model
models for the homeostatic control of
interceptive variables.
They write the generative model models
shown in figure three, which we'll look
at after this slide, afford the
homeostatic regulation of a single
interceptive variable, which we call
here body temperature. For illustrative
purposes. Much like a thermostat, this
model maintains the requisite body
temperature by reporting the discrepancy
between predicted and sensed
thermoreceptor activation given Bayesian
beliefs about temperature triggering an
autonomic reflex u resulting in, for
example, vasodilation, which resolves
the prediction error. So if the life of
the organism were just to hang out on
the beach and vasodilate to off heat
when it needed to and then to constrict
and to save more heat when it needed to,
that's the biological task that this is
going to be describing, which is just
one facet of an organism's biology. But
there are experiments that sometimes
only measure temperature. And so
thinking instrumentally, this single
factor model, this single variable model
on body temperature may be sufficient
for some experiments or it may be useful
in certain cases. So just because it's a
simple model doesn't mean that it's not
going to be very educational and
provocative, but also even be sufficient
in a lot of cases. But no one's even
claiming it's realism. That's why it's
written this way. They say citation 20
for a fully specified example. And that
is a citation two. Chance et
al. In March 2022. So still in the
future and they write, we start
from the present premise and this is in
the paper that again is from the future,
we start from the premise that the goal
of interceptive control is to minimize
discrepancy between expected and actual
interceptive sensations I-E-A prediction
error or free energy. Importantly,
living organisms can active this goal by
using various forms of interceptive
control. Homeostatic allostasis, goal
directed. So there's more details in
this paper, but here in figure three
is where they're going to show it. So
keep in mind this generative model
structure. And now these are going to be
in a different form. And here in the
caption, I'll describe what they say.
This is the homeostatic, the first,
most ancestral, or just
the simplest possible. Just go
make it darker if it's too bright and
make it brighter if it's too dark. Make
it warmer if it's too cold. Make it
colder if it's too warm. That kind of
first order cybernetic loop.
This generative model includes an
interceptive, thermoreceptor Y
observations and a belief about body
temperature x. So that's the beliefs
about how the body should be. And that's
again, the beliefs playing that dual
function that the paper 37 drew out,
which is that on the left side of this
equation, failure to satisfy the
preferences is dealing with this P
distribution as a inference. But then on
the right side, p has to do with
expectations that are being either fit
well or poorly. And so this is where
active inference has a slightly
different architecture perhaps than some
other theories. The beliefs are about
body temperature. It's not an estimate
merely of the external body temperature.
Crucially, the prior over X is kept
fixed and hence it acts as a cybernetic
set point. Well, you can't just expect
what's going to be best for you. You'll
die, right? If you die, you die. But if
you enact policy such that your
expectations are realized, then you
persist. That's why we're studying
things that are persistent. Any
discrepancy between the predicted,
thermoreceptor activity given beliefs
about X and the measured Y is registered
as a prediction error that is canceled
out by an autonomic response. For
example, a thermoregulatory response.
This is shown as an illustrative plot of
the expectation of prior and posterior
observation and autonomic actions over
time. So here is like the action policy
which is like be at the baseline level
of thermoregulation and then kick in
some sweating or cooling mechanism.
And then here it describes how the
observations start at about 37 one and
then they steadily start climbing. And
then the belief, which is initially like
things should be 37. The posterior,
the after evidence estimate starts
creeping up and then it hits a certain
value and it engages a critical
threshold that turns on this thermal
regulatory response and then that cools
the temperature back down. So this is a
basic architecture for doing first order
cybernetics and that kind of first order
logic. Here in this figure, the red
circles represent the expected values of
X, which are used to make predictions
about Y. These are subtracted red arrow
with the rounded end. So this one from
the measured Y to form a prediction
errors. Dark Bleu circle epsilon, which
is used to update the expectation and
drive action. Light Bleu circle you
here's, you that changes
why? Such that the prediction error is
resolved. What if it doesn't do it?
Well, then the system dies. So we're
talking about evolution where we've had
like for the ants, 120,000,000 years
allegedly for that to get Pruned out and
even longer at the cellular level. Note
the lateral modulatory connections in
the allostasis network, which we'll get
to in a second. So just to take one
little discourse, they say C 24
for details. What is PAP 24?
It is Friston, Par and de Verise, 2017.
The graphical Brain belief Propagation
and active inference. Let's just look at
a few parts of this awesome paper. So
first they have a table with definitions
of the technical terms. So just to kind
of read a few. But it's kind of awesome
to see the authors do this. And this is
in great paper as well. So how do they
define generative model, generative
Model or forward model?
A probabilistic mapping from causes to
observed consequences data. So from
hyper parameter to the parameter,
it is usually specified in terms of the
likelihood of getting some data given
their causes, parameters of the model
and priors on the parameters. So it's
all relative in nested models, but this
is generating data like kind of cranking
out like a music box possible or
plausible data sets with similar summary
statistics, like similar mean invariance
of some distinctions or similar
parameters if there's a whole vector
that describe it. And then the
recognition model is related to
learning where new data are coming in
and discrepancy is being minimized. If
the generative is outputting the exact
same mean invariance that encoding data
are having the discrepancy is low, the
predictions which are about preferences
are being realized successfully. Action
policy is working well or better than
expected. Flip everything and you have
the opposite situation. And then just to
give one more definition here, because
the next slide will feature it, so the
others are also good to read.
Factor Graph factor graph is a bipartite
graph where two distinct sets of nodes
are connected by edges representing the
factorization of a function, usually a
probability distribution function.
Formulating a Bayesian network or model
as a factor graph enables the efficient
computation of marginal distributions
through the sum product algorithm.
What does a factor graph look like and
how does it relate to the kinds of
Bayesian graphs that we've been looking
at? So on the top is not the Bayes graph
that's distributed across this slide,
but another variant that we've seen a
bunch of times, which is the partially
observable Markov decision process. So G
expected free energy minimization pi
policy selection is influencing B,
which is how S the latent state in the
world is changing through time. There's
D the prior on the hidden state and then
a the mapping of how the state is
related to the observation. And so
depending on how the models framed,
those can be learned or not. But it
turns out that because of how this is
relatively sparsely connected within a
time frame as well as across time
frames, there's a way to use this
bipartite construction called a factor
graph that splits up those unlabelled
edges which are statistical dependencies
and kind of interweaves functions which
have a slightly different
representation. And it turns out that by
interleaving these functions into the
variables, it's possible to make what's
called a factor graph and that gives an
order of operations to arbitrary or
within a certain set any kind of
Bayesian graph. But it includes this one
importantly. And so here is the one,
two, three time points and two policies
are being selected and that's what this
graph represents. The organism comes in
with a priori time step one, two,
three, there's two actions. And then
here's another figure from the paper
where at each of those three time steps,
one, two and three little figure
at time
steps one, two and three. So at times
step one, that's like anticipation and
planning. At timestep two it's like
short term anticipation as well as
memory. At timestep three it's like
memory and it's always now casting as
well. And so one can imagine that this
is a really useful format because it's
extremely composable on one hand. So
just like they said, okay, well we kind
of have this motif with three time steps
and they connected us. What if D from
the top level came down and was S
at a lower level? And we've seen that
taken to a really elaborated extent as
well as interpretation in for example,
the paper on mental action in Live
stream 25. And so factor graphs are
awesome because they're basically
needing to only be specified in the
Bayes graph format. But then it provides
not just a mesh connectivity but a
process algorithm and a heuristic and
approach that's actually tractable. So
we get the composable analytical and
graphical component that's an
intractable algorithm.
The next section is generative models
for the allostatic control of
interceptive variables. So this is going
to be the first real modification of the
homeostat that's introduced in three.
This is going to be the base case, but
it could be something else other than
body temperature. The homeostat is
simple but limited as they write. It can
counter sensed changes of body
temperature but cannot anticipate
predictable changes of body temperature
or other variables in nature.
There are several regularities eg night,
day or seasonal alternation that can be
easily incorporated to extend the above
generative models as technically
speaking, empirical priors. The obvious
advantage of predicting how our bodily
and interceptive variables will change
is being able to exert some anticipatory
or allostatic control. And so this is
kind of getting into the second order or
anticipatory cybernetics also related to
Rosen's anticipatory biology.
So here's figure three C.
In A and B there was just the homeostat
returning us to a set point after
something got triggered and now there's
going to be the affordance for
anticipatory control. This generative
models sketched out with the same scheme
as the previous slide. This generative
model extends the homeostat by
including. A second set of exteroception
variables that correspond to light
intensity y two and a belief about
sunrise x two. That's the sun visual
side on the right. Furthermore, like the
visual system and the left side is still
the temperature and interoceptive
system. Furthermore, the model includes
a predictive relationship between
sunrise x two and body temperature y.
This edge isn't saying that the sun
warms the body. It's saying that in this
model there's an edge reflecting a
statistical dependency and that's where
there's a degree of freedom with respect
to the blism and instrumentalism etc.
In this way inferring A, sunrise can
trigger the autonomic response U of
thermal regulation in an anticipatory
manner, that is, before the sunlight
actually increases body temperature.
The other part of A and C are Bayesian
networks highlighting that Y is
conditionally dependent upon x with the
directed arrow between the notes with
more than one x and Y. In the model for
the allostap, the lower parts show the
form of neuronal message passing that
could be used to solve these generative
models. So the Bayes graph is
represented on the top and then there's
the message passing with respect to the
neural correlation. So that's kind of
the second aspect
of figures three, which is just bringing
in multisensory integration or even it
could be like two pixels, for example,
with beliefs about each other or
something like that. But that's what
allostasis is going to be enabled by is
just by this duplication of a column and
then this connection in a different way.
And then here's the third section of
four seven generative model models for
simple behavior control. And so they
write the
homeostat and the allostasis permit the
control of simple forms of swimming,
flow, motion reaching and other
movements. One biological example is
provided by the Zebrafish Virtual
Reality study 30 which identified the
neuronal underpinnings of error
correction during escape behavior in the
animal's telecephalon. It's a brain
region, brain evolution conserved set of
brain circuits involved in action
selection in other vertebrates,
including mammals such as the cortico
basal ganglia circuit. So that's about
the evolutionary anthropology of the
brain region. And then here's just some
pictures from the paper by
Tori Go. At all 21 zebrafish
capable of generating future state
prediction errors show improved active
avoidance behavior in virtual reality.
So they did a learning task that
involved the fish being able to
differentiate a signal and then they
studied the role of anticipation in
that. And the authors in this paper use
that as an example. Maybe we could talk
about that or other examples in the dot
one and the dot two two,
section eight.
Here's where we get to the very
interesting operations that are going
to bring this sort of descriptive model
of different kinds of homeostatic
allostasis and intermodal and then
behavioral regulatory elements into the
evolutionary context. So our central
argument is that evolution proceeded via
gradual elaborations of the predictive
motifs illustrated above. Under genetic
constraints and opportunities and the
selective pressure of novel problems to
be solved, such as the control of more
sophisticated bodies in the presence of
richer ecological niches, e. G when
Vertebrates began to establish life on
land some 400 million years ago. Over
successive generations, generative
models can remain stable or be
elaborated along four key dimensions,
strongly limiting the space of what is
evolvable. So what are the four kinds of
dimensions that are going to be changed
that is going to be discussed in terms
of the changes that can happen to the
specifics of the generative model.
We have introduced the first kind of
elaboration from the unimodal homeostat
to the multimodal allostasis. So they
kind of secretly introduced this
transformation between figure three A,
B and figure three C. So that was
secretly like one of the
transformations. A second kind of
elaboration is the duplication of
predictive motifs which enlarges the
animal's behavior repertoire.
The third and fourth dimensions equip.
The generative models with temporal and
or hierarchical depth respectively.
These two expansions enable richer
predictive motifs that endow a cognitive
sophistication, such as the possibility
to plan or consider events that change
on multiple timescales. So it's the
evolutionary algebra on structured
learning because we're outputting a
structure, this graph g, which is going
to be like as if the species over
evolutionary time is going to be
implementing some graph in terms of the
structure of its model. Like if there's
a case where the Kant is not integrating
the polarization of light with the
olfactory system and then there's some
change in the model that actually
integrates them and then some
relationship is least, whatever that
means from a realist or instrumentalist
perspective. And that is going to be
like an evolutionary algebra. So it's
not going to be like two x minus three
x, but it's going to be more like that
than not because there's going to be
operations and they're going to happen
in order. So here's figure four
where they represent their evolutionary
algebra. Figure four, the five main
dimensions of elaboration of generative
model models introduced in the paper.
So it was four dimensions.
Then it's five dimensions. There's
evolution in 4D by Chablanca and Lamb
that would have been good to add to the
five main dimensions of elaboration of
generative model models introduced in
the paper, illustrated as operations of
an evolutionary algebra. So here's the
five operations. And so we're starting
with on the left side, that homeostat,
that simple corrective calibrative first
order cybernetics model, either what the
system is actually doing or model of.
Then there's going to be five
information that can happen and then
it's showing there's a second round,
like once you go H, you can go HTA I
plus I or I. So you have five discrete
options at the first time step, but one
of them is no change. So it's kind of
like no change or four different layers
of excitement of the electron like four
quanta. But they're for discrete
operations like a deletion or an
insertion in genomics. And then from
there it's just the state for the next
time step of the model. And then
something else happens. So what are the
operations? The bottom is I, which is
the identity operation that leave to
generative models as is. So that can be
interpreted as like a non mutation or
just a conservative mode which is how
most inheritance works. Then the second
one is the duplication operation I plus
I. So it's like identity remains the
same but then there's a duplication.
Literally it's like a genomic
duplication but in this functional space
replicates existing predictive motifs to
form parallel sensory motor loops. A is
the operation that was described in
figure three. C the allostasis operation
endowed the generative model with
horizontal predictive relations between
different modalities. And so the
implication would be like going from one
sensella, one antenna to two antenna
or going from one photoreceptor to two
photoreceptors. But the actual
architectures of the column of the
photosensory transduction cascade would
basically be computationally or
statistically unchanged. And then the
allostasis is actually bringing in this
horizontal aspect. It's not just two
duplicated systems next to each other.
Now there's actually connections between
them and of the possible kinds of
connections across columns. One of them
is like this classic allostatic motif.
Then there's the ones that we haven't
gone into as much, which are T. The
temporal depth operation extends the
generative models with separate
variables for past, present and future
states. So it's kind of from a graphical
perspective what we looked at in a
difference between the first factor
graph which did take action at three
time steps three timesteps like
the thermostat does to the one that
actually has either prospectively
looking anticipation about future time
steps or retrospectively looking memory.
But that's how the factor graph comes
into play, that's temporal
depth. Then the hierarchical
depth operation H extends the generative
model with separate variables for states
of affairs that change at different
timescales faster time scales at the
bottom levels and slower time scales at
the higher levels. Hence modeling
narratives such as music and language
where nested timescales are relevant.
So to kind of split that idea of
temporal depth into two pieces, there's
incrementing the number of steps you're
looking in the model that's increasing
the time horizon on policy selection and
increasing the temporal depth within a
level. And then there's this notion of
nesting levels within each other.
That's the nested generative model and
therefore nested Markov blanket
discussion that we've been having and
that is going to be connected to
cognition activities like narrative.
And the reason why they're very similar
is that the time scales can kind of blur
into each other. And so it's all about
the models structure as stated. Like
this one is hierarchical and it has a
depth of three. It's a two layer model
and it has a depth of three, three time
steps are included. And it could be
different if there was always looking
two ahead and always looking to in the
back. Then the model in the computer
would need like a minimum of five time
steps. But the entity's model could
still be restricted to S minus two, s
minus one, and then S plus one, s plus
two. So those
are the two ways that it can expand in
these two temporal and hierarchical
ways, which is to nest hierarchical
model to become temporarily deeper with
a longer horizon given the nesting
structure. So these are all structural
changes. That's why there was the whole
piece about structured learning because
it's as if or actually like over
evolution time there's the structured
learning happen. And then if we use this
partitioning and Bayes graph approach,
then hypothetically, any kind of
evolutionary starting point if we go
back far enough and then final state,
if we have all the transitions, could be
modeled within like a native active
inference framework. Section Nine
they're going to go into a little more
detail about duplicating, predictive
motifs and enabling multiple behavior.
So they write, how does
this duplication of the model looking at
it from the outside, it's like as if
they're acting as if there's two models
looking at it from the realism in the
inside. It's kind of like thinking about
the real duplication of a cognition
function that's functionalism or like
even a neuroanatomical region like the
earlier examples with the retinal cells.
And that's like canonical realism. So
generative models can expand by
duplicating simple predictive motifs to
form a larger repertoire of species
specific behavior such as approach
avoidance, the control of the vibrace
and visually guided grasping classic.
The operator I plus I in figure four
illustrates a generative model in which
the same predictive motifs are
duplicated and specialized to form a
behavior based architecture composed of
multiple parallel sensory motor loops.
So they're suggesting that because these
are your affordances, your operations in
your evolutionary algebra, you can go
from this starting point, it's kind of
like go to leisure balk starting point
and then doing operations to it.
Because you have the starting point and
the operations to it, it allows you to
get to even relatively advanced motifs
like approach avoidance, etc.
But a key piece is duplication because
implication of something without
changing it is how you are able to build
more land to experiment in, so to speak,
build more space. And I copied
some images from genetics specifically
in the relationship of how gene
duplication and divergence in the early
evolution of vertebrates this paper.
And there's a huge amount of cybernetics
and genomics works on the duplication
and divergence and the
neofunctionalization, the
subfunctionalization. Because if you
have like an enzyme or essential gene a
now to go into the whole gene thing
totally another time though, you could
have the function of the second copy in
the genome be lost and then there is
still like a continuous line of
function. So if you only needed one copy
of a then this would be sufficient. And
then other times when you have a and
it's dual function like it binds to two
different, not exactly similar
molecules, then when there's a paralogy,
when there's this duplication, it allows
subfunctionalization or new functions to
arise. So that's how people talk about
it and link it to realism in genomics.
And this is kind of approaching that
from a cognitive perspective.
There's probably more to say, but we'll
talk more about the duplicating of
predictive motifs. So how is duplicating
predictive motifs enabling of multiple
behavior? Okay, they write from a
structured learning perspective,
duplication is an efficient way of
building generative model models. And
that's what it's all about in the sense
that the dynamics are conserved over
different sensory motor domain. This
conservation is mathematically akin to
factorizing probability distributions on
the generative model that has been
discussed in terms of modular
architectures and functional segregation
as a principle of functional brain
architectures in Bayesian Statistics
physics, this kind of factorization is
ubiquitous and known as a mean field
approximation. Indeed, the free energy
bound on model evidence is defined in
terms of a mean field approximation that
affords an accuracy and minimally
complex explanation for sensory data.
And so what are some of these citations?
44 modular architectures for
factorization of probability
distinctions in the generative models
par Sajid, Karl Friston 2020 entropy so
here is kind of a cool figure,
nice graph and then there's
the message passing and then citation.
48 the mean field approximation what is
it? Here's a paper from 2001 and
they wrote algorithms that must deal
with complicated global functions of
many variables often exploit the manner
in which the given functions factor as a
product of local interactions, each of
which depends on a subset of the
variables. Such a factorization can be
visualized with a bipartite
graph that we call a
factor graph. A wide variety
of algorithms developed in artificial
intelligence, signal processing and
digital communications can be derived as
specific instances of the sum product
algorithm, including the
forward backward algorithm, the Viterbi
algorithm, the Iterative turbo decoding
algorithm, pearl's 1988 belief
propagation algorithm for Bayesian
Networks hashtag Markov blankets, the
common filter and certain fast fouryear
transforms FFT algorithms.
So it was 21 years ago when this
was happening and now we're here.
OK? Section Ten endowing generative
models with temporal depth supports,
perspective and retrospective Inference
so just like we looked at with that
factor graph, giving this operation
over evolutionary time enables that
factor graph to arise from something
with the lower time horizon. The
generative model models discussed so far
only consider present states and
observations. However, they can be
expanded into temporally deep models
whose variables explicitly represent
future and past states and observations.
So this is what the operation looks
like. It takes XT and then at
XT plus one or tau depending on how it's
written. And then now there's another
time step appended to the end of this
model, either actually or as if here's
something cool that they wrote. They
wrote various researchers have
speculated that a major driving force
for the development of deep temporal
models was foraging. So why would this
happen functionally? Which is to say,
why does the mutational spectra,
which does allow for this as an
affordance end up selecting four and
retaining and enriching force
temporarily deep models? Otherwise we
wouldn't observe it to exist and they're
connecting that to foraging.
Intriguingly, this is a vertebrate
example. The same hippocampal circuits
that support spatial navigation and
foraging are also involved in
prospection and imagination. This has
led Buzsaki and Mosser to propose that
prospective function have leveraged
cognitive and predictive maps in the
hippocampal entorhinal system. And hence
mechanisms of memory and planning have
evolved from mechanisms of navigation in
the physical world. So what are the
cognitive demands of foraging? How about
information foraging? How about mental
foraging? Here s some awesome papers by
Hills and Cuisine and others foraging in
mind and foraging in semantic fields.
How we search through memory. So what
about mental foraging? What about
individual and collective foraging?
This is an awesome paper by Feynman and
Corman in 2017 and they talk about the
continuum and the complementarity of
individual and collective approaches to
cognition. And so implicitly, like
foraging as a phenomena some of the
affordances and the neurophysiology of
foraging in ants, it's the same
materials and mechanism that any other
insect that's not eusocial has. So the
detection of light, the intensity, the
wavelength, the polarization, sometimes
the ability to do chemo sensation like
taste and smell, mechanical reception,
etc. And the same action affordances too
like movement. And so there definitely
is nest mate levels cognition in ants.
But also there's things that are of a
few different interesting types. One of
them is meso scale like small group
dynamics, stochastic teams and larger
scale like colony and even colony niche
stigma g and ecological scale cognitive
processes. Like these two ants are
interacting and modifying each other's
foraging behavior, mechanistically and
statistically. But also it wouldn't
happen unless the niche were exactly
this way which they have also in their
extended selves established for
themselves. So how do we think about
individual and collective foraging and
stigma g in complex systems and mental
foraging and cognitive demands and
cognition security? What about section
eleven endowing generative models with
hierarchical depth affords multiscale
inference. So now we get to the
hierarchical operation that is going to
give that multiscale inference. So far
we have described generative models that
can deal with aspects of the world that
unfold at single timescale. So plus one
plus one plus one timescale is temporal
depth. But you're getting still only one
extra per transformation.
However, they can be expanded into
hierarchical model models whose
variables at different hierarchical
levels encode latent states that unfold
at different timescales. One example is
a song. Melody remains the same even
though the notes we hear or sing change
rapidly and speech. Similarly, a movie
or narrative remains the same for
several minutes. Scenes remain the same
for several seconds, but visual stimuli
can change over hundreds of
milliseconds. Such models permit
hierarchical models permit modeling of
narratives,
songs, movies and other events that
change at different temporal scales by
encoding variables that change more
slowly eg melodies or movies at higher
hierarchical levels and variables that
change more rapidly. Egypt notes or
visual scenes at lower hierarchical
leave to neurobiological examples of
hierarchical organization are visual
areas in mammals and areas that control
vocal gestures in birdsong, which has
been studied active inference lab
several times. And so here's another
quote from the authors in more advanced
animals, the hierarchical control of
action may have expanded into
sophisticated forms of cognitive control
and executive function. Layer one
scare quotes which help prioritize
digital goals while inhibiting immediate
affordance. So it's not just about
seeing deeper within a time scale,
but it's about being able to pull up to
a higher time scale and then from there,
after the H operation, it can be
followed up with a T operation. So
here's the minute scale and then there's
a hierarchical implication that allows
for the hour scale and then that can go
into 2 hours and now two minutes. So now
there's a twohour and two minute long
model instead of a 1 minute. And it was
just two computational. But if the two
computational had been or the three
mutations had been just going deeper
within the minutes, it would be a
different outcome. How is
that functional? So what is the function
and the cost of temporal depth just
instrumentally? When we're studying
diverse cognitive systems, how can we
detect temporal depth and versus
hierarchical nesting? Then what is
the meaning and the role of narrative in
cognition? How does this relate to
narrative information management?
All right, section twelve. Getting
towards the end in the above, which was
again the description of the simple
motifs in 4567 and
then the evolutionary algebra in eight
and then several of these finer scale
discussions on nine and ten. In eleven,
we then get to twelve. In the above, we
formalized brain designs in terms of
generative models that include
predictive loops of various complexity
red and then discuss the five main ways
in which generative model designs can be
elaborated. Green or the five main
interactions of an algebra of
evolutionary structured learning.
Figure four. This means that one can
describe the evolutionary trajectory of
brain designs in terms of a limited
number of computational operations over
generative models. Bleu so here
is a phylogenetic tree on the right side
with the tree of life.
One of the tree of life.
What are alternative complexity or
traditional ways to think about
phylogenetic trees in evolutionary
biology? Are phylogenetic trees
interpreted instrumentally? Are they
interpreted under a realism framework?
Is that what really happened to those
species? Or is it our model inference
about what is the relationship between
active inference in the free energy
principle and evolution?
Okay, they have figure five, which gets
at their phylogenetic model. So this is
a phylogenetic free of generative model
designs and putative correspondences
with animal brains. So here's the
implied interface states and then I is
going to be the identity operator. So
here the orange species has not mutated
at all. Now, sometimes this
is conflated with simply being an
outgroup. Just because it is that way
doesn't mean they're making the
conflation. But sometimes people will
make the conflation. That because a
species is an out group to some other
clade that has been included in the
analysis that it is the basil or
primitive form. And so it does happen to
be that way in this example that the
basal is the so called least derived or
most primitive or basal form. But my
personal thought is that it should not
be described. And Tim Linsker and others
have awesome writing on that evolution
fallacy. So in the rest of the tree,
which is being focused on, different
kinds of operations happen. So here's
that I plus I implication and then
there's no change after that. And then
this one has a and so on. So just like
you could trace the phenotype changing
through time on a tree inferred from
trait or genomic data, which is just
another trait, this maps up to certain
changes that are seen neuroanatomically
over vertebrate evolution. And it
reminded me of this paper, which was
Chakra Borzi and Jarvis 2015.
And so that is the paper, brain
evolution by brain pathway duplication.
So they don't connect it to in the exact
same way, the neurocognitive and the
functional and active inference lab and
all that. But this paper does get out
some of the very similar ideas about the
functional duplication arising as a
result of pathway duplication.
They have a section on brain complexity
and pathway evolution. They talk about
some alternative hypotheses and then
talk about distributed and duplicated
morphological structures. So it's a kind
of interesting paper from about seven
years ago. Another paper that's very
related to this idea of doing like an
evolutionary algebra with combinatorics
but also a path dependence is this paper
pretty recently, just a couple of days
ago by Ryan Smith, Maxwell Ramsden and
Alex Kilner. The paper is why Bayesian
brains perform poorly on explicit
probabilistic reasoning problems. So
look at this tree that they have the
starting point and then three action.
So here it's like divide, divide,
multiply, divide, add, divide.
And then they study that in the context
of Bayesian brain and doing
calculations, why is it hard to multiply
numbers together sometimes? So then the
authors of the paper 38, right?
Interestingly, the mutational operators
are commutive. The same generative model
design can be obtained by executing the
same operations but in a different
order. The communication property of
mutational operators potentially sheds
light on the conversion, evolution and
the process by which unrelated organisms
evolve similar traits independently and
via different evolutionary histories
when they need to adapt to similar
ecological niches. That's pretty cool.
All right, so just the discussion and
then a few last points. So discussion
and the authors summarize it in this
article. We suggest that brain structure
or design could be formalized as
generative models agree disagree that
the brain generative model models of our
evolutionary ancestral included simple
predictive motifs agree disagree and
that the evolution proceeded via
successive elaborations of these
predictive motifs into more brain
architectures that we observe in
advanced animals. They then talked about
the ways that that can change through
time functionally. And then they write
while the evolutionary trajectory of
designs for predictive processing
proposed here is certainly tentative and
incomplete, we consider it a first step
towards the alignment of predictive
brains and evolutionary studies of
neuroanatomy in different species. So if
this is the first step, where are we
headed and why do we prefer and expect
ourselves to be there or go there?
Just a few more topics that we could
talk about, like in the dot one and then
the dot two. First would be they write
that the error correction mechanisms,
in their view encompass the simple and
the complex forms of adaptive behavior
hashtag intuitive theory. And they're
going to argue that that differs
significantly from prevalent
perspectives in psychology and
neuroscience, which tend to separate
sets of mechanisms for sensory motor
processing and simple cognition. So how
is active inference similar and
different to other frameworks for
behavior? What are the building blocks
of adaptive behavior? What are the basal
blocks of just any kind of behavior?
Where does sensory motor integration
come into play? How about mental
functions and cognitive functions like
memory, anticipation, counterfactuals,
etc. Okay, another point
to kind of think about or write your
questions down and reflect on is the
perspective which is still speculative
and not unchallenged suggests that the
complexity of the ecological niche
determines the level of complexity that
the brain needs to have in order to be
Bayesian optimal. In other words,
brains only increase their complexity
with sufficient ecological demands. So
not necessarily just that mutational
direction and intensity will go towards
increasing brain complexity from
ecological demands. The Socalled
anticipatory evolution that cognitive
entities can have through
selfmonification and niche modification.
But even for those that aren't actually
doing anticipation still it could be the
case that when the ecological demands
are such that a behavior model increase
in complexity is selected for and
retained, then evolution will go that
way. This is because having a more
complicated brain does not help if you
live in a simple niche. So that's like a
very costly model that's not giving you
any more return on investment.
They then talk about how the social
brain hypothesis states that the
necessity to predict and deal with
sophisticated social dynamics was a main
driver of the evolution of large brains
and sophisticated cognitive abilities in
our species people. In short, the
gradualism expressed as a progressive
increase in complexity rests on the
circular causality implicit in the
modeling of an eco niche that is itself
constituted and constructed by
increasingly complicated phenotypes. So
because it's so important to think
through other minds first just how
you're going to materially avoid a
spatial collision. But then, so the
social brain hypothesis goes, includes
increasingly recursive levels of game
theory, market theory, and all this kind
of stuff, and related indirect cognitive
phenotypes required like memory and
recognition, narrative understanding,
rhetorical understanding, governance,
et cetera. That is,
being positive as compatible with
the models the authors have written and
a hypothesis that others have written
about, not from active inference lab
perspective, though in most cases. So
what is the cognition niche for social
entities, our material niche and our
social cognitive niche? What is the
social brain? What is the use social
brain? How are they related? So for
example, the social brain is saying that
the more social things are, the more
sophisticated the brain has to be. We
need more narrative understanding and
more memory. But what if in the Eusocial
case the brain is simpler on board for
examples, it's more role based or
temporal polyethym has allowed more
reduction in each phase of the life
cycle brain. So does
social lead to you social? How does your
sociality arise and how does it
elaborate? How do different kinds of
sociality arise and elaborate? And how
is that associated with the different
kinds of models structurally changing
that we've been discussing in this
paper? And then just genomics all the
other stuff gene expression and then
just one last point, which is the
closing piece of their paper too.
Finally, it is important to acknowledge
that brain design bodies ecological and
cultural niches covolved independently.
Not sure if that was meant to be meant.
It's kind of like they are codependent
in brain evolution but they coevolved.
They were alone together. Given that
here we were interested in the evolution
of brain designs, we assumed a brain
centric perspective and conveniently
focused on generative models in the
animal's brain, hashtag realism in
the brain not modeled as in the brain.
However, cognition does not need to be
confined in this goal to be it can be
extended outside it to COVID for
example, tools and social dimensions,
epistemic niche, niche modification,
digital stigma. Furthermore, the body
design and not just brain design plays
an important role in solving control
problems, acknowledging that cognition
niche be extended and embodied and
encultured, etc. All the least, all the
other letters suggest that not all
aspects of control need to be solved by
or represented in a central generative
model. Tail of two densities all the
discussions we've been having about
representation and so it was X and X
star in the simple version that was
presented in this paper where it was
actually. Trying to track X star in the
world with the internal inference. But
this is the discussion that we've been
having action, action, action oriented
representation structurally resemble the
world. And there's other papers that
we've discussed in the last several
weeks that really touch on that point.
So how do we think about generative
model models and factor graphs for
extended cognitive processes? So, a
couple of books to check out about
extended mind and embodied cognition.
And then here's a nice figure from touch
points with the brain, the organs in
the body, the world and the tools and
the epistemic niche and the computer
like a calculator and time chronos and
food and then other people social. So
that's like cognition is like a holistic
interactions of all these features.
What does embodiment this perspective
have to do with realism and
instrumentalism and utilitarianism and
other philosophical positions?
Are people really taking those positions
or is it just as if they're taking those
positions? And then what else are you
really curious about and motivated to
explore? And how will you modify and
improve your epistemic niche? So I hope
you enjoyed this kind of Solo Zero
video. I think it's been a little bit
since the Solo Zeros, but just want to
close, as always, with what might a good
understanding enable? What are the
unique predictions and implications?
What are the next steps for free energy
principle, active inference, lab
research and application? What are the
goals of this research and what are you
still curious about? We're going to be
talking about this paper in the coming
weeks on February 16 and February
20 free. And so if you'd like to
participate in those discussions through
live chat or by joining the discussions
live, just get in contact with us. Hope
you read this paper because it's very
thought, provocative and interesting.
So enjoy the paper and work
through it. Hope to see you in other
action flow activities. Thanks for
listening and your regime of attention.